oh i'm playing um i'm playing my
long forgotten father
okay oh we haven't played in so long
how do the pieces move again
okay
i haven't played hecaro in ages was the
last time i played hikaru
man i beat hikaru a single time on
chess.com
it was like that one bullet game it's
somewhere on youtube i was like beating
hikaru's
botez gambit so my most recent game
against hikaru
was this one maybe an arena kings
when was this i don't it says like the
name of the
oh the tournament starts in 30 seconds
also thanks for all the hype i
appreciate the train
oh i play the stafford against zacaru ah
i remember trying to look for the vod
i i think i lost the vod of this um
this game because i did stream it
i have to check my hard drive
anyway if i got a chance to play a
stafford against recaro or against
anyone else
and hopefully have a few staffords this
tournament
let me unmute okay
okay i think we're good to go this is
3-0
oh 3-0 okay
okay deep breath thanks for all the bits
i do appreciate it
and practically a goose subbing for two
months
of queen b6
i'm out of prep now maybe the sizzle
move
i vaguely remember having a tournament
game i did this stuff
like c3 will defend the knight with the
queen discover defense
also blocking the check
also let me know if the layout's okay um
i
kind of did it last minute but it should
be okay
so i can play b4 here
i'm chasing the queen all the way back
and probably this move
at some point i want to play h5 maybe i
should have played h5 sooner
oh did i blunder
i kind of actually maybe it's not so bad
i forgot that i'm gonna lose c3 but i'm
gonna win back a pawn
hopefully but there's this okay i'll
take twice
okay that was kind of lucky but i'm
getting rewarded for
i mean developed all my minors
oops i have to be aware of click click
oh thank you morgan appreciate that ten
dollars
also jot.com thanks for the the sub
and so many other people let's take and
take
the pawn is a bit weak now i might be
threatening to take and take
still ideas of h5
yeah why not a typical move
wow i'm black being confrontational
thinking um congrats you're tied for
first
oh well i guess we're all tied for first
at the beginning of the tournament
also tied for last but i always got to
look on the bright side
okay so rook see one so if the knight
comes here i can move away and threaten
bishop c7
yeah this is now a threat i'm actually
threatening to trap the queen
so rook a7
i guess we trade i might play this and
go for that
that's a very respectable move
i'm thinking i'll just trade and play
positionally
like castle i don't want to take the
pawn because then bishop a6 would
be hurtful so the plan is my knight e5
and then go after the pawn
and say up on time
yeah we could trade some more you know
black takes and
dark squares become weak around the
king's side
i might play rook c3 here
some future ideas of swinging over or
just doubling up
i'm pretty happy with the peace harmony
coordination
need some queen a4 knight c6 idea
like very solid position everything's
defended
kind of a traditional london formation
with the absence of my h-pawn
what is this so it takes takes takes e5
i'm probably i want to move the queen
no no rush to take the pawn
i'll put time of time now too
[Music]
i could play a queen c2 and make a gun
let's do that
we could trade everything but up upon up
a ton of time
uh e4 looks nice
there's some d5 move coming
when you have knight in bishop and your
bishop is of in this case a dark square
usually you want your pawns on light
squares
to just compliment the bishop
in this case i might play 95 first
wait a minute 95 might not work
maybe just a3 kick the queen
uh okay now we can trade
i'm winning another pawn there's bishop
d3
yeah and e5 is a threat as well
so i guess we'll end up trading
i keep trying to kick the bishop around
bishop's almost trapped
but not quite
this point it's just a matter of time
[Music]
how to do this oh my time is low too
i was a little bit slow there but there
we go okay
decent start undefeated in arena kings
2021 let's go
oh that might not last long but okay
we're gonna be optimistic and focused
play one of these undefeated
yeah let's go i have to savor it while
it lasts
i'm going for this move ah
so this move
i think i can still go for this idea
seems like white is moderately prepared
i vaguely remember like taking
i know i've looked at this line before
i still want to access the square
also preventing that font from moving
because e3 would be weak
question is what to do maybe this move
whoa it's wonderful blunderprone
the twenty dollars let's go
i really appreciate that
i think i want the knight here this is
what we call a kappa blanca knight
kind of it combines really well with the
pawn structure
very typical for these queen's game
decline positions
okay white wants to play e5 i have g5
here
g5 is a legal move very emote worthy
move now i can take the knight
not sure if it accomplishes much
queen c7
i mean knight f2 is coming
so i have knight h5 it's kind of
interesting
and then g4
not entirely sure to do here
there's queen b6
so i'm preventing d4 because then i can
take knight a4 i'll play queen a7
i think i just want to double up
confusing position
h5 here
i kind of want to play c5
making things spicy
i feel like i'm getting outplayed down a
lot of time
okay now i can potentially take
we trade and i win d4 in the end
okay i probably missed that
g5 is a target
you just queen e5
i do knight c493
some some d4 idea too
okay i want to play b5 soon
never mind
this move white's going to have to trade
put the pawn on f6 and f3 is a constant
target
if we don't train i'll have neither four
played i don't know what to play
uh that was probably really bad
okay so we're gonna trade oh white did
tactics to me
that was a nice tactic let's try and
break through
it doesn't work though
there goes all my hopes and dreams
ah i'm getting mated resign okay
that was a good game i felt like i was
that's a game to analyze later i was
doing well when i won the pawn
on d4 then that time was kind of an
issue
okay can't complain or can't be uh too
upset
i guess i could complain
okay so this is a line i get every once
in a while
some like kind of catalan type structure
thing
um yeah usually when you can you want to
play c5
and philip proth philip roth thanks for
subbing
with prime i appreciate it
um okay let's try and stay focused fc4
maybe
probably bishop a6 first
maybe bishop b7 because knight b5 i'll
play knight a6
and there's this move which i kind of
forgot about
no that was a mouse slip i meant to play
knight a6 not bishop a6
i'm losing a i'm losing a thing
how bad is this
this is pretty bad
losing the exchange and upon
i could resign
i'll fight for a few moves
i can't even blame click click for that
yeah white has a winning move here
even though the position's already
winning yeah good move
actually maybe i'm holding on a little
bit
no it's so bad
unless to try this
i just want to stay down the exchange
so light stacked at peace is going to
win the night back
clearly debating which knight to take if
takes
uh this way i have knight c6
takes this way i take and defend
and then i'll resolve the pin somehow
so trying to stay alive
my dream would be to like play f6 and
win the pawn
uh which is kind of hard to
i want to play e5 here but and d5 is
loose
i guess i could just kind of chill
[Music]
like put the rook in maybe this at some
point
maybe somehow like prepare e5
interesting move
i just want to keep the game close and
keep my opponent thinking
okay v5 i think i just play rook c8
and now the bishop flocks so the pawn's
a goner white doesn't want to take
because then
lightswords become very weak
queen d3 maybe night some some point
night before
it's a tricky move
um that's a good move
i'm just gonna have to roll with the
punches
really okay i was not expecting that
um but how do i punish this
if i take with a rook
i'll go for this
f3 is going to happen
and then i make loofed
luft while also trying to attack
and works tied down to the f pawn
how i'm surviving this queen b5 coming
so i'll play this move defending the a
pawn
queen beef oh never mind wait that's a
free pawn
wait that's made in two and also a free
pawn
wow i was kidding i survived the mouse
slip
i mouse slipped losing the exchange and
then i kept surviving
i was on the verge of resigning too
but that's why i guess i don't
i don't like to resign
okay playing v-shaped tiger
my grandmother died today
i feel bad laughing i feel kind of bad
laughing
but thanks for the money um
well what's a play
also thanks for the gifted subs
something hawkeye
what do i do here queen e2
bishop b4 is coming you're just a3
i guess bishop d6 is coming
it's weird but i'm kind of being
brainwashed by my opponent's username
v-shape
okay now my now it's a mini-v
hmm look at this move
just preventing b5 if c5 i'll get the
b5 square
it's kind of a weird stand still because
neither of us want a castle he's doing
the cava blanca knight thing
so i think my knight wants to be
elsewhere
like on g3 and then maybe slowly but
surely i'll
prepare some center break
some idea maybe stacking but i'm just
going to chill for now
i'll probably end up playing f3
oh that was hanging
i guess i was hanging well here's my
pawn
i just lost a pawn that's okay
every pawn lost as a file opened
um play this move
okay time is also important
i'll never give up yeah i'm trying
it's not as bad as the previous game
down the exchange on the pawn
oh he's doing the v shape thing but it's
an upside down v
uh i play c5 and now maybe maybe this
point may i can do the same thing he did
to me
but with the a pawn
okay expected i kind of want to play
b4 actually i have no idea what to do
here
i'm just gonna chill with the rook maybe
i'll play rook b1 b4
the rook is hard to remove actually
um gives him a target though the queen
should be here maybe e4 ideas
am i trapping the queen the queen is
being hugged by its pieces
but it's being hugged too tightly
and if he fives just uh then the queen
is completely surrounded
uh so i win at night
wait this is really good i just have to
manage my time
why are so many good things happening to
me
yes i can't speak too soon
trying to make a gun there we go there's
my gun
ah okay ah
i have this move okay i'm gonna force a
queen train
there we go
that's going to be tricky
oh
stop hurting me
that's a draw no draw
oh i feel so dirty i won because i have
a pawn
if he took the pawn it would be a draw i
think
did his v shape oh his v shape was kind
of
uh it was something okay wow so i've
i've won
three and lost one so far playing josie
wales
stafford gambit no stat oh maybe
stafford we'll see
no stafford
so we have a italian i guess
i think here i'll just leave the
[Music]
the bishop on c5
a very positional game so far
a lot of tension
i actually don't know what to do maybe
b5
like we're both kind of just building up
waiting
for the tension to be released
okay
i guess we can keep trading i'll have c5
in the end
i kind of want to play d5 that's
interesting move
that looks wrong because i'm aligned
with a thing but there's some alignment
this way
oh i just drop a pawn
oops i have d4
i kind of just dropped upon
my bad okay so i have this move
with some eventual check maybe
that's not good though
or is it
take it's confusing
a lot of things align with a lot of
different things
down on time as usual so the point is if
takes i take and things are defended
lights also kind of pinned to c2 and
thank you
sir zaki rochester something
wait did i no i didn't play komsky did i
did i play komsky who's this
i dirty flag komsky oh i feel so bad
i if i knew that was komsky i would have
given him a
i oh i oh
i feel really bad he's like the one
person i would give a draw to
he even offered me a draw man um
i didn't know that was komsky
probably good thing i didn't know i
would have been more scared if i knew
oh just move
in trade questions
oh thank you well makes me feel less
guilty i guess
i do appreciate the the thousand bits
i played comskey on lichas in bullet
uh maybe about last year
uh videos on youtube is like one of the
most wholesome games i ever played
like we were complimenting each other
during the game
we're streaming separately
okay i gotta focus here is the bishop
trapped
no my knight's hanging there my bishop
might be trapped though
rookie 5 but we're t8 so maybe this move
king f4 man doesn't look right for white
how do i punish this
this move i don't know what this does
but maybe knight h5 could be an idea
very confusing position
and now i want to play like king g5 g6
or just g6 anyway
i'm not sure
i guess i have knight g3
i wouldn't be surprised if i had
something better there
oh i forgot about that move
yeah no this is bad
this is really bad
okay let's fight somehow
this is what i get for dirty flagging
komsky
karma that crumbled really quickly
it seemed like maybe i
yeah i should have played g6 maybe yeah
g6 because if takes there's f5
and if take six six there's knight g7
okay
oh thank you pie hole for the karma bits
yeah i have to do more good deeds
hopefully better things will happen
playing renato terry yeah a lot of these
people like renato terry
josie wills i used to play a lot like in
the
previous seasons of arena kings
i kind of want to play queen f3 here
some e4 idea maybe not
okay so there's this move coming
working both pawns
i think i do this is this just an
opening trap
vlog will probably get compensation
somehow so i have nothing developed
but it looks like i'm winning a pawn
um black has everything developed so
[Music]
i have to be very very careful here
if i cover c2 we could end up trading
the structure is really ugly for black
i'm not sure what to do if lock just
plays something like rook c8
or that
queen h3
actually queen h3 is nice because i
defend the pawn i prepare to develop the
bishop
maybe te2
that's kind of terrifying
but what's the worst that can happen
we trade
some calculating takes takes takes rook
d1 preventing knight d3
oh h7 was hanging two probably too risky
to take though
it should be on my radar
okay so we're going into this
so i prevent knight d3 which is kind of
the main threat
um there's a move that i've kind of
forgotten about which is this or that
i do have knight e5 now e5 could um
[Music]
95 just loses a rook
i mean what else d
i mean knight g1
maybe knight g1
it's so there's actually very few moves
the box fighting mates i mean queen e6
is a
this material queen e6 is a choice
i think i'll try this
and then pray so i defend this and i hit
the queen
but i kind of undevelop
and i could take and then take i have
knight left two
or even even better there rook rook g8
this rook could hang in the end
okay that's a good sign
keep offering a queen trade i mean
there's this move
or that move
i mean now my left three
i can still legally castle i think i
haven't moved my king
i just move my knight back and forth
i'm up a piece here wow
oh but the castle loses a bishop
it's probably worth it though
because if takes i oh i don't have
knight b4
i have this
i didn't think this through
um oh i have knight c4
okay same idea and the idea is just to
threaten um this pawn
which is attacked twice
i don't think black has a good way to
defend
okay we're gonna trade everything
and it's gonna be a time scramble
oh actually
just have to move quick
let's go okay
i couldn't tell how much time like it's
hard to play the moves and then look at
both clocks because my eye has to
my eye has to look down and up so
okay somehow it's fast enough let's go
i'm wait what do you what do these
numbers mean
i forgot how the format works through
that focus
my ninth place or my 176th place
oh also i messed up the opening oops
yeah this is not a good opening
um
i guess i have to take
that's playable
i wasn't paying attention to the move
order i'm 175th place what
i thought i'm doing well but there's a
lot of people
oh there's actually 870 players
okay threatening upon
oh that defends its castle
and keep queens on the board hitting the
knight
might have some idea knight a5
yeah that didn't really do so much
let's retreat
da my pawn i guess we could trade
wait a minute
it's so risky to take that
[Music]
yeah i don't think i'll take it i'm
calculating a queen a5 bishop f8
there's b4 i'm moving too slowly too
all right let's try this
knight c4 incoming
that's 284 i guess
there hi how's it going
sam tam thanks for that
that's a difficult position oh i'm
getting forked
the knight forked my queen and another
fork
i could resign i could cry
or i could fight i'm down about a minute
i've been down the exchange before
nothing new
the problem is i don't know where my
counter play is
just have to make things complicated
ah good move
not getting made it just yet
make a sandwich
i don't know what to do here
all it takes is one fork though
or one skewer
i'm fighting still oh i'm getting mated
just as i say that too where's the
resign button there's a resign button
okay
that was rough i tried to fight
i set up some blockade
okay life goes on the pairings don't get
easier
i think the the algorithm is just set so
i play players around my rating the
whole
tournament
sticking with london
how do you enter the tournament there is
arena kings command
but then uh
i guess you have to go to chess.com live
and then go to tournaments tab
and you will hopefully find it
okay this is a fun line if takes takes i
defend
here i'll um get the bishop pair
get some better structure
i'll probably put the queen on h3 i've
had very
very similar positions before
the problem for black this pawn it can't
be defended by any neighboring ones
and
it's on the half open file so long term
i can
hopefully build up something
now i might play knight d4 i might
transform the structure a little bit
and go for some eventual f3
the f3 is now a threat
put the queen in some idea of lifting
and mating
i don't think i want to trade unless i
unless i do
there's bishops he won
[Music]
yeah i'd rather keep the bishop here
the idea is to eventually take and then
go in for the kill
but yeah maybe i'm not getting so much
that's not what i wanted it should still
be a little bit better
because i do have the bishop here
so we're just trading into like some end
game
the goal is still to target the d-pawn
like g3 preventing any battery
that may have been the wrong move
that's supposed to equal i might even be
slightly worse here actually
and that is strong
okay i think i'll simplify
yeah black played as well playing like a
blitz champ
okay so i have this move
i'm not scared of takes takes check
because it's just f3
and bishop wants to go here
um you can still play f3
the queen here i have queenie one
oh but move order all played
oh this is bad
actually how bad is this it's pretty bad
this move
i'm safe it's still unpleasant though
i'm just using the king
it should be a draw
no i'm losing
no ho-ho was i losing the whole time
where's the i couldn't find the resign
button
was i this the question is was i losing
after the queen trade it might be losing
here
or no i can just kind of chill i should
have just moved back and chilled
f5 was a bad move i panicked
i thought i was going to get zigzagged
but
ah okay life goes on
playing this person again man
i'm struggling to stay in the top 300
b3 b3 is a bit early
okay looks reasonable
that's a very typical move
i just want to encounter the bishop
yeah i think i want to take first
maybe even queen takes e5 i'll just play
this end game
or queenless middle game it's nice when
the pawns over extended like this
because
i have the square to work with
and bishop can plant itself here
that's a good move
i'm gonna have to move back
i might want to play f5 at some point
but maybe not right now
i guess he doesn't want me to play f5
that's still interesting
just have to keep the pace
yeah i'm maybe getting ready to do it or
maybe not
good move
trying to evaluate the minor piece like
if we trade all the rooks
it looks like it's happening
hmm
that's a risky move the pawn might be
weak but i'm trying to target this pawn
yeah so move like e5 here
this is the whole plan to get the
outside passer
and white can't actually defend i guess
like a counter-attack
or that move
that's actually a really annoying move
so i can play this
over the bishop there's a weird position
if takes i take here if takes i take
here
so now i have a outside past a pawn
it's more expecting the past h pawn
takes okay let's attack a knight
now this pond's dangerous
hmm
ah i'm too slow to calculate
no wait what's going on
no
oh i kind of messed this up
oh good move too
my thing well played
oh yeah it turned into a race
maybe i should have just like kind of
bailed and taken
and then use my king and then go after
this pawn
inside hindsight
man i'm struggling to finish in like the
top 50
of this tournament and pairings don't
get easier
but we have a stafford kind of
okay let's try and actually i still
don't know how the
how the point system works
because it's is it likely chess or it's
not likely chess
like if you're on a like there's some
concept of having a streak
but i guess to get points you need to
win games which i'm
i'm failing to do
trims thanks for subbing with prime
and cosmic hero soothing the pain of
losing
appreciate the prime subs and laksanae
oh it's taking really long here a bunch
of playable moves
good luck thank you yeah i need more
luck
probably some more skill too
what's a good system for black most
black openings you kind of have to react
to what white's doing
um if you want something like low
low effort scandinavian
can get like similar similar structures
to london
or king's indian type thing
there's some cases where you can play
like a stonewall
a stonewall dutch would be another
recommendation
okay so i'm trying to keep my my time
advantage
but not my bishop here so this move
i kind of weakened c6
okay there's some holes on the king side
now
i'd love to get a queen to h2
how to do this
96 is a move and it's still bishop g3
though
it's an interesting idea
i didn't calculate this fully but idea
bishop g3 queen here bishop takes king
h8 i'm threatening queen h2
that's not so easy to stop
i'm also hitting the bishop
bishop moves its mate because the rook
would cover f2
the question is am i getting mated first
which i might be
i really want to take on f7 i would have
to take with rook
i have rookie 8 there might go for this
uh
[Music]
i didn't calculate this fully i did see
queen e3 in the calculation
okay that's enough to win yeah because i
take on c1 with check
okay that was nice
thank you barbecues wow that ended kind
of abruptly
i thought i might just lose quickly but
i guess not
uh what was this
i'll play reverse london because why not
have like a
structure that resembles kero khan
i did lose a few tempe but i have a good
bishop
and there's b4
b4 maybe i would take
this doesn't seem so bad not used to
playing a structure like this so
it's a5 queen a6
f5 could be some issue
it gets weird though wow it's getting
very weird
not f6
now i'm defending d5 i'm gonna lose that
5.
i'm very confusing sequence
oh i'm losing exchange
so many games i'm losing the exchange
good move or the a3
and kg one's coming or that
interesting
gotta try this
yeah so all of this i kind of saw coming
[Music]
oh i guess i'm losing d5
i'm trying weather the storm
preventing bishop c6
i want to play this move
[Music]
and just try and hunker down
turning this now
nights can be tricky sometimes
it's kind of best case scenario
this move it's kind of risky
that's probably just a bad move with
bishop three
nights gonna go on a walk
no oh i'm already losing though
yeah i forgot my pieces were
the resize button is not working there
we go
uh yeah that was a clever move
i'm kind of disappointed i didn't put
more resistance there
but at least it ended quickly
quick and painful i think you expanded
dingus
for something with prime okay let's try
and break into
the top hundred how about just a small
goal
wait what is this line 95
so i got like one extra tempe actually a
couple extra tempe
usually the bishop on g3 here
that's looking very nice here
defend the pawn going for this move h5 i
probably sack i almost definitely suck
and files are about to open up
regardless
yeah just want to bring the other rook
in
i'm just calculating bishop g6
there's rook h7 too actually
it's probably more efficient
yeah definitely more efficient okay that
was nice
playing a marna music [ __ ]
musicovich okay let's play this move
there's really no downtime
the game starts pretty quickly
hey top 300 working my way back
up
yeah i want to play queen a4 but it's no
good i have this move
i do 95
yeah some interesting move order
going for the copa block and knights
and i saying the knight defends b2 just
kind of holds the position together
maybe 93 coming
oh i'm losing a pawn
i guess i'm losing a pawn unless i'm not
queen b6
confusing position
i might be losing two pawns queen b6
knight e3 knight a4 queen b3 i'd lose a
pawn
or wait no we would trade queens there
and then i lose a pawn
okay this doesn't look so bad
and pawns are equal have i passed a pawn
i might be losing my a pawn oh there's a
cool tactic though
it takes and then rook
doesn't work
it might it might not
let's do it
so idea after takes takes the rooks
can't really defend each other
i am down the exchange but this is kind
of falling
take their first
so my knight is yeah my knight and king
are a bit stuck
but the queen's always tied down to the
mating threat
so and the bishop can never attack the
knight
we might end up being at a standstill
i might actually want to shift over and
threaten mate like that
um
it's getting murky i visually it looks
good because i take but
it's not entirely clear
so i check and move here bishop d4 i win
the bishop
there we go let's go
okay everything wins at this point
just untangling
trying to untangle
let's go okay that's a cool game
it was uh some kind of back and forth
thank you your boy bishop nusub at tier
one
okay so i guess i have 16 total
tournament points
i think earlier i asked how the score
works and then i didn't look to see if
anyone responded
but how the streak system works
i guess is the main question
wait a minute bishop f7
doesn't quite work
h3 here
yeah if anyone knows how chess.com
arenas work
it'd be nice to know probably look it up
after the stream
okay let's play um bishop foreign
idea knight d2 is a very typical kind of
benoni move
maybe f4 coming
oh i'm sorry one dumb hick oh i see
okay i see your your link i appreciate
that thanks for sacrificing yourself
just share the link um play f4 here
can i untime you out
oh i think you're untimed out
e5 interesting move
i think i'm going to get a structure
with um
defended past d pawn is at some point
we're either going to trade
or if takes takes knight would have to
come to e5
question is do i take with knight or
bishop
i think knight
okay so i might want to make use of the
file
and the one thing i have in the position
along with the nice center
if ever f6 i have bishop e6
oh thanks ipsy okay i'll
take a look closer look afterwards okay
i think now it's time to take because
this is my bad bishop anyway and now
rook f6
so winning either of these pawns
because there's rook e8
and queen g4
counter-attacking
there we go
so i'm controlling these squares so the
rook has to move away from defending f7
so you're in true points by winning win
is worth two draws one
if you win multiple games wait i'm slow
at reading
uh can i take that
g5 queen e6 gg
bishop's attacked vision moves queen c8
what is this
okay
if you win multiple games in a row the
value of each successive win increases
oh second winning we started three
points
oh and every consecutive win you'll
receive
ah wait so it's likely chess
oh except you go up by two rather than
one
i'm trying to play the game while like
internalizing how this formula works
so the max you can get for a win is four
if you're on a streak
and to get a streak
you need oh like three in a row okay
three in a row you get the bonus points
it sounds like
maybe i'll clarify afterwards
um why not
also thank you m piper 58
with a sub so two three four four okay
okay i think i understand
yeah interesting position and bishop is
a good piece
i mean focus is on e5 right now
at some point i'll probably relieve the
tension
this bishop is actually a garbage piece
we could trade
i'm definitely worse here unfortunately
it's actually really difficult to find a
[Music]
move
like rook here may rook e8
because i want to take and queen takes i
have f6
it's really uncomfortable still
okay now at least i have that
oh it's considering sacking and playing
queen g5 and
i think that line's okay for me rk7 in
the end
scary though okay we're going into it
yeah this could actually be kind of
painful
careful how i do this
while f6
wow i didn't see that coming
i resign ah that was rough
not my proudest game well i win my next
game wait did that refer to how that
last game or this game
hopefully this game can try and make up
for it
we have a dutch
um i'll play one of these
okay pressure's on
yeah hopefully this game doesn't finish
before the the prediction ends
it's getting sharp
so bishop a6 is the idea
i think i want to take a 95.
now it's getting weird
so i want to play f3 promise takes takes
g5
c4 is interesting
bishop c2 bishop c2
just threatening to take preparing f3
i have still some issues with g5
so bishop a65 queen g4
hey number 220
even numbers
i like the position
how to proceed
so plans to play e6 queen is also now
tied down to g7
i might see rook g8 but now i take the
pawn actually
okay probably going into some end game
up a pawn
question do i take with pawn
that's a close call i think i'll take
with a rook
more active
moving a little bit too slowly
i'll play this move
probably should have played c4
i'm moving way too slowly
[Music]
hmm
i'm meeting close to meeting
no
no
opponent didn't still made me ah ah it's
completely winning too opponent blunder
the rook
it's like it's annoying
to track the pre-moves though
because i i pre-moved everything not
realizing there was a race and then to
unpre move
i was too slow sorry people
but congrats to the people who voted no
i guess
good job narcolepsy gang
and that was a good game too um
i'm playing daniel marino
daniel mourinho is like an og i believe
of the stream
i remember playing daniel moreno in like
simuls
when i first started streaming i think
okay i'm a little bit tilted from
that last one but life goes on
okay more of a positional london setup
oh i forgot there someone was saying
there's a challenge to
pre-move checkmate i don't know if i've
accomplished that yet
30 just under 32 minutes left
okay so black has a bishop here position
is kind of
comfy for black but
i think we're both kind of comfy here
assumed to be pawn diamond
this is preventing any shenanigans
i probably don't want to push the pawn
because it gives away some squares
it's nice having a nice wall of
pawns like this
okay time is nice
i'm just trying to keep up the pace
i guess no pawn time in this game
i'm winning yeah rook helps attack
through
x-ray
now i'm getting a fork
or not i guess there's takes
[Music]
hmm
oh what to do
a sneaky trap
there we go that's what i was waiting
for
it should objectively be winning because
my king is sheltered by the
f pawn i can even play
this move
um
there we go
okay that's close good fight
i'm just trying to put together a streak
22 oh
i'm playing vortnick man it's so hard
pairings really are like i don't get uh
so many easy opponents
i don't even know what i'm doing here
knight c7
i'm just trying to keep pace i
appreciate that
thanks so much wind finder
trying to keep pace oh what do i do here
b6 and bishop a6 that's a sad plan
and the pieces are kind of just trash
but sometimes you have to dig through
the trash to find
hidden gems
hmm
somewhat of a risk
it might just be completely losing
but it might not be so it takes takes
king b1
takes takes takes takes
rookie three
might be completely losing
i guess i have king h7
so the line is uh ticks ticks king one
takes takes
uh takes takes king h7 rookie three
and then i kind of cocoon
ah there's queen g4
i could just start by taking here
okay queen of sixes coming wait this is
not so bad for me
it's still complicated king's gonna run
to f1
[Music]
probably
wow a very bold decision
this is crazy
wow
no my rook disappeared
no
oh that was rough that was a cool game
um i didn't see anything for me
rookie 2 is a nice move
okay next game no time to waste
the thing is if i finish like really
badly in the standings
i can only hopefully go up from here
for future weeks
okay so i'm playing um kind of an
anti-danish
this is all prep so important to play
queen c4 stopping away from castling
if i were to take the pawn i would lose
a queen because takes takes
also pressuring this knight so the main
move is queen
usually queen e2
we can end up trading
um that's not a main move
oh it's gonna have some issues with the
king now
hopefully
maybe not
i guess not it's going to be positional
i probably misplayed that somewhere
but okay i'm not a bad position
or is it takes takes
okay so the calculation was takes takes
check king c and the king just
kind of chills on d7
i'm up upon not going to take a draw
um but it still takes work to win
uh maybe i'll put the king here
a bishop is running low on life
that was nice okay
uh okay playing slippery something
something
wait is this the person in first place
oh this i'm playing first place
but i'm 218th how does that work
oh maybe we have we just have similar
ratings
and this person's above hikaru so hikaru
is probably rooting for me
i need to channel hikaru's positive
energy
i should take lessons from hikaru
and teach me his ways
i feel like i'm getting outplayed in
this move
okay maybe it's not so bad
can trade queens some f3 idea coming
oh hey karo passed okay
oh good job hakaro
um
that's a move so might be oh it might be
three or that move
hmm
getting ready to double up
[Music]
it might be worth playing this
and bishop versus knight
threatening knight f6 now king e3 coming
yeah this b4 move might be coming
you can also take with a rook probably
doesn't make a difference
that's probably close to equal
and still all three results possible
i'm down some time
takes
so f4 f4 loses a pawn though
hmm
let's go it's winning i think
let's go
oh no wait no this is still winning i
think
i better be winning
let's go okay i won let's go that's why
end games are important
also time management is also important
will eric promote a pawn
oh next game oh i'm playing um
i'm playing my long forgotten father
okay oh we haven't played in so long
how do the pieces move again
okay
i just want to be solid
don't hurt me
in this move defend the pawn
he's trying to be tricky
such a sneaky person oh it's not too
sneaky though
i'm losing a pawn ah
he was being sneaky
okay maybe i can be sneaky back
threatening queen c7 maybe
that doesn't do anything
okay i want to play 94 and there's some
some counter play hopefully
have to pray
why do i feel like i'm just getting
smashed
it's like a rose and smash but the wrong
direction
is queen here like you're here
etc
okay we could tell we could trade i
don't think i want to trade though
there's f4 crazy move
now this is really uncomfortable
oh i have a cool idea though
i have a really cool idea watch this
watch this
double pin it's almost as beautiful as a
double rainbow
and then it takes i uh i take on e6
ah he sees tactics
i have to play this
uh he sees tactics
i thought he was being clever
i mean i have knight of three here
i'm still trying to fight
now my time beautiful time
i spent too long i'm am i threatening
something
i might be threatening something
what is this i have to go for it
i have no time
[Music]
oh he played so well that was a cool
game though
i don't know what happened there
somehow it got really messy
i didn't see bishop d4 and then
i mean there's counter play despite
being down two pawns
even here maybe queen e8
but i don't have perpetual okay
yeah he's good at chess
okay now from here it gets easier
hopefully oh
let's play play one of these
yeah that was our first time playing in
about a year i think
it's been so long
i wanted to play stafford against him
too
um anyway okay let's focus
to play
my bishop just trapped
i guess i can move back
that was not plan a
let's trade everything
yeah at least at least he's gonna win
the tournament
i really helped him because i i beat
slippery speeder
and then i i lost to hikaru
um let's take
hey welcome back pam yeah if you're just
joining
um it's arena kings it's about to wrap
up almost
had to do this
this maybe f4
just trying to close things down it
takes takes my here
thank you tacio salad oh toss your salad
yeah i like my salads tossed
okay some idea to attack from behind
yeah knight wants to land here
[Music]
so there's some threat of taking the
pawn because the g6 pawn is pinned to
the knight
a cool idea it takes i play f5
i'm just taking advantage of this um
kind of weird pin
i'm threatening to win a piece
which way to take
so many options
so i'm threatening rook d1
also this move
cool idea of takes i take here first
king has to move somewhere and then i'll
take bishop c6 i have checked
um
that's a bad tree move um okay
so i'm up two pawns black wants to maybe
it's a weird position
i'm down on time
oh and i'm losing another pawn wait this
turned bad really quickly
now i'm down upon
no
i feel stuck
that's not still meet
okay last game final game
actually the uh the final game might not
count
i think there is a prediction right if
i'll play a title player
ah no stafford that's so sad
no one's going into saffron
let me have a i think i'll just copy all
of my opponent's moves
very low mental energy
uh yeah why not
oh okay now it continues
how long can i keep it up
it's so symmetrical
was that oh that was a sound
opponents still baffled
because every move i'm giving my
opponent a taste of their own medicine
oh no wait a minute if i play this
does that not work it doesn't work i
have to take
ah i can't copy the moves anymore
i feel so sad oh now i can do something
ah the tournament's over congratulations
hikaru
yeah it's a weird like it's a weird
format because
low rated players can do well because
they're not playing against a higher
rating group
so congratulations to these people
having good performances
um
yeah i don't know what to to make of it
um
i guess it gives everyone kind of a fair
chance
but also um
that's a lot different compared to the
arena format on the chess
isn't it bad just a copy yeah don't
don't try this type of thing at home
um i played this kind of knowing that
the the game was gonna
get aborted or adjourned no aborted
so the next gm was cree core
900 player top 10 that's crazy
yeah the um
[Music]
they must have changed something like
the last arena kings
season this was in 2019 it used to be
most of the title players were on the
top
but now it's uh it's a lot more
scattered i finished 240
but every game i was playing like very
strong opponents
oh wow this is my first time playing on
shots.com
of 2021. my last game was almost a month
ago
i didn't realize i took that long of a
break so i have the chest.com games
in it's like a pgn format
um i'm not sure how many games i
actually played
but then what i can do
i can just bring them into a leachate
study i think
so the way to do this is to
[Music]
it's been a while since i've done this i
think we just copy the text
and then pgn paste hopefully this works
okay so i played 22 games overall
i'm curious to look at the hikaru game
because we went into a line
i looked at briefly at some points not
too long ago
i figured out like entirely what to do
it's just kind of a playable position
how did i do so my rating
my rating at the end of the tournament
was 2561
at the beginning of the tournament oh
it's 25 46 so i gain rating points
i thought i did below average but
i guess i played a lot of high rated
players
so we're officially done with the
tournament i think i'll stick around for
a little bit
at some point i'll wrap things up it's
been a long day
but i guess there's a few things i want
to look at
i can try and answer some whatever
questions people have in the chat
but uh yeah let's see let's see where
things went wrong and let's see if i had
any like missed opportunities
um
i think yeah i'll just have the engine
on just to get some quick feedback
a4 yeah when he played a4 it was
i always had to be concerned about a3
so a4 is actually a very logical move if
he plays b4
okay then i take and c6 is weak
okay
picaro is like really good in these sort
of positions where
both sides kind of do their own thing
and he waits for the mistake
long time no see leetsku oh
oh i am avalon i still have the unopened
avalon game wait right
yeah look at this i bought this
over a year ago i have yet to open it
it's still in its original packaging
i think when you first subbed when you
first subbed i
i had the game someday i'll open it
it's kind of sad though because no one
no one comes over to play
also thank you bye eric subbing with
prime
i first my very first game of avalon
was with
it was with nepo
aronian a few other like grand masters
was during one of these like sink field
cup events
anyway yeah that's what people used to
play before um
before among us
anyway okay i was much worse here and
then
there are some interesting tactics okay
i was happy with f4 even though
engine really doesn't like it because
what
ended up happening is bishop f5
and my original calculation
was if rook because rook takes c3 looks
so natural
then i was gonna play this and say oh no
my queen
and then mate
if we got this position um
it's interesting because i'm threatening
mate and if takes takes
queen f7 only legal move i take with
check and then i
i save my queen and i'm winning um
so that was a hope
but he took on d4 so basically killed
my hopes and dreams
wait engine says rook c3 rookie 6
oh bishop d my bishop d4 king h2
oh the king has h8 stockfish is good at
chess
okay so this happened
played knight f3
wow so it's always losing for me
oh then here wow queen a3
here i just took on g6 i had i had less
than 10 seconds left
so it was rough
queen a3 very sneaky threatening mates
and whatever like if the queen tries to
defend in some way
i have knight c6 wow
that's a hard move to spot but such nice
geometry
because like here you're trying to
attack on the king side so
uh it's so natural just to like focus on
this
half of the board
but the key is to move as far away from
the king side as possible
to still attack on the king side because
this is a mating square
and geometry is so tringy
triangular it's so beautiful
almost a right triangle
okay so i took on g6
and then i'm just losing
maybe could have resisted a bit more
i was trying to stack all my pawns like
i was hoping for this
and then this and then this and then
this and then this and then this
i was hoping for something like this and
if takes i would play this and he would
pre-move this
hey it's ben what's up then thanks for
reading
i was just showing my game against akaru
this didn't happen this didn't happen i
flagged before this happened
shout out to ben feingold i assume ben
played arena kings as well
i hope you finish better than me i
finished in like the top
top 300
wow then gained 71 points
that's actually kind of impressive
that's really impressive
i was just showing my game against
takaru where
ah you be me